(squeaking hinge)
- [Voiceover] Good boy,
Apricot, you're a good boy.
(relaxing music)
You're a good boy.
Let's relax and get a massage, okay.
Good boy.
You're a good boy.
Hi, you're a good boy.
Yeah, you're a good boy.
Hi, baby.
(puppy grunting)
Okay, just relax, sweetie.
Just relax.
That's it, baby.
Good boy.
You're a good boy.
That's a good boy.
Just relax, Apricot.
Good boy, good boy.
Good boy.
What a good puppy, yes, you are.
Sleepy, sleepy, puppy.
Oh, you're a good boy.
That's a good boy.
(squeaking)
Good boy, Apricot.
Apricot, you're a good boy.
(pleasurable grunting)
Good boy, good boy.
That's a good boy.
That's a good boy, Apricot.
What a good puppy you are.
Yes, you are, the best puppy.
That's a good boy, yes, you are.
Hi.
(puppy cooing)
Hi, baby.
(squeaky grumbling)
Oh, that's a good boy.
Good boy, Apricot.
That's a good puppy.
Good baby, that's a good baby.
I love you, yes, I do.
Good boy, Apricot, good boy.
You are so precious,
you're a precious boy,
yes you are, yes you are.
(wiggly grumbling)
You're a good boy.
Hi, Apricot, puppy.
(wiggly grunting)
Hi, baby, hi.
Good boy, Apricot, good boy.
Good boy, good boy.
(pleasurable squeaking)
That's a good puppy, that's a good puppy.
(squeaky moaning)
Oh, baby.
Good boy, Apricot, you're a good puppy.
You're the best puppy in the world.
Yes, you are such an angel.
That's a good boy, that's a good boy.
Hi, baby.
(groaning)
Baby.
That's a good boy.
Good boy, Apricot, that's a good boy.
Good boy.
Good puppy.
Do your other side?
I'm gonna do the other side.
Good boy, Apricot, good boy.
Good boy.
What a good puppy.
What an angel you are, yes, you are.
You're such a good boy.
Good boy.
What a good stretch, Apricot.
That's very good.
Good boy.
Good puppy.
Such a good baby.
Good boy.
Thank you, Apricot.
Are you relaxed?
You're a good boy.
Sleep good, little angel.
Sleeping baby.
(squeaking hinge)